-My first guest is an Oscar,
Emmy, and Golden Globe winner,
starring in the new movie
"Locked Down,"
which premieres this Thursday
on HBO Max.
Here is Anne Hathaway!
Oh, that's what
I'm talking about.
Anne, welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
You look fantastic.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Thank you so much.
I'm so happy to be here.
-I've known you for
a pretty long time now.
-Mm-hmm.
-I've heard people call you
Annie, like, your good friends.
Do I call you Anne or Annie?
-Call me Annie.
-Yeah.
-Everybody. Everybody,
call me Annie, please.
It's -- Can we talk about my
name for a second?
-Yeah, of course. I'd love to.
-Okay. Can we -- Can we really
get -- Let's spill the tea.
So, I -- You know,
when I was 14 years old,
I did a commercial
and I had to get my SAG card.
And they asked me, "What do you
want your name to be?"
And I'm like,
"Well, it should be my name.
My name is Anne Hathaway."
Like -- And I never --
And so that seemed like
the right choice,
but it never occurred to me
that, for the rest of my life,
people would call me Anne.
The only person who ever calls
me Anne is my mother,
and she only does it
when she's really mad at me.
Like, really mad.
-Yeah, I know that.
-And so every time, like,
I step out in public
and someone calls my name,
I think they're going to
yell at me.
-Yeah. My mom would say
my middle name.
"James Thomas!"
-So, is -- But I doubt people
are just like, "James Thomas!
How are you?
Loved your last film."
People are like, "Anne."
I'm like, "What? What did I do?"
-"No, I'm Annie!"
-And so, please, seriously,
just feel free.
It's not --
People are so lovely.
They don't want
to be presumptuous.
And so they come up
with workarounds on set
because the truth is,
nobody is comfortable
calling me Anne ever.
It doesn't fit. I'm an Annie.
And so people
call me, like, "Miss H."
People call me "Hath."
So feel free,
call me anything but Anne.
-Well, Annie, congrats,
by the way.
Since the last time
you were here,
you had another baby.
You have two
beautiful boys right now.
Congratulations.
How old are they?
-They're 4 and they're 1.
-Oh, my gosh. During quarantine?
Has it been crazy?
Just perfect.
-What hasn't been crazy?
Like, yes, like, on the list of
things that are crazy --
It's been a lot.
But, I mean, those are good ages
to be home with your kids,
because, you know,
our 4-year-old believes
everything we tell him.
And that's adorable,
as well as very useful.
And our 1-year-old
is just, like --
It's just the most magic age.
You know, we've just been home
with him since he was
4 months old,
just with him every single day,
and that's been a gift.
-Yeah, that's pretty wild.
-But the 4-year-old --
Did you, like,
tell your kids everything
when they were 4, like,
to kind of get them to do what
you wanted them to do?
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, yeah, sure, whatever.
I still kind of do it, yeah.
I'll just go, "We'll do that,
and then we'll get this."
But, yeah, I mean, I was --
When they were really babies,
I was trying to get Winnie
to say "dada" so hard,
to make that her first word.
-We know. We know, Jimmy.
-Do I have the book around?
I don't. But if I did --
-Well, I have the book,
and it works, darn it.
-Dude, I was calling
everything "dada."
I was calling the bottle --
-You jerk. You jerk.
-Really? I was calling
the bottle of milk "dada."
-We should have
talked about this before
so I could really
let you know how I feel.
-I also put out "mama."
I have "mama."
You got to read that book.
-You didn't send
that one to me, sweetie.
-Oh, you know what?
Quarantine. It's in the mail.
-Oh, yeah. No, no.
Of course. I understand.
I have to. I have to understand.
-"I have to understand."
-But my 4-year-old --
it's the best,
because over the holidays,
like, this was the first year
he's really believed
in Santa Claus.
And we were driving in the car,
and you know when, like,
you're in the car
with your kids,
and, suddenly,
the car just gets too hot?
-Yes.
-Like, all of a sudden,
like, in a second,
and everybody gets, like,
loud at the same moment.
And the baby is crying
because he wants the cracker
that the 4-year-old has,
and 4-year-old will not
give him a cracker.
-Yeah.
-And, like, just won't do it,
won't do it, won't do it.
And then, finally,
I just have this spark
and I go, "Okay, Johnny,
but what about Santa?"
Like, his hand shot out
straight towards me.
I had the entire
box of crackers suddenly.
There was no argument.
And Adam and I turned to each
other, and we went,
"Oh, my God,
this is so powerful."
-Wow. What did we just -- That's
right.
So, 4 and 1, you know, the ages
are the ages that they are,
but there's a lot of
magic in those ages.
-This -- You know, I tried not
to do Elf on the Shelf,
just 'cause I go, "I don't know.
I have enough things
to worry about, you know,
and to have the
Elf on the Shelf thing."
And you want to hear the
weirdest thing?
It showed up in my house.
We do it now.
-What do you mean?
-The elf is in my -- Somehow --
I don't know how we got it,
but the Elf on the Shelf
is now in my house,
and it does stuff every holiday.
-We had to come up
with something,
because, like,
Johnny would leave the room,
and then Jack would mess
with his stuff.
And Johnny would
come back and be like,
"Who messed with my stuff?"
And we came up with
the demolition elves.
-What? Oh, interesting.
-So at nighttime --
at nighttime,
after he went to bed,
the demolition elves
messed with his stuff.
There's nothing
we could do about it.
Like, "No, it certainly wasn't
your brother,
who you're now going to
whale on --
now you're
not going to whale on."
-I want to talk about
your new movie, "Locked Down,"
because it's so --
-You're saying that very well.
-Thank you.
Well, I don't want say it's --
It's not "Lockdown." It's --
-It's not "Lockdown."
It's "Locked Down."
You're right -- I guess you do
have to kind of --
-I just wanted to make sure
people can hear the title.
-Honestly, have a glass a wine
before you watch the movie,
it'll be "Lockdown."
-"Lockdown."
"Babe, honey,
let's just watch it.
I don't care."
-Let's just watch "Lockdown."
I don't know. It's on HBO Max.
-HBO Max? Yeah, we have that.
-Yeah, sure.
It's one word. Who cares?
"Lockdown."
It's a fun heist movie,
but, also,
there's a little love in there.
And funny.
I thought it was fantastic.
How do you describe the movie?
-The story -- So, I act in it --
It's directed by Doug Liman.
So if you're a fan of
Doug Liman movies,
you know to expect a lot and
many different wonderful things.
And I act
opposite Chiwetel Ejiofor,
who is just a dream.
Oh, my God. He's amazing.
And wonderful in this.
And he's never played
a part like this before.
And we play two people in
a long-term relationship
that has run its course.
And the day after we have our,
like, can't-take-it-back,
end-it-all rager of a fight,
my character gets a call
that one of my co-workers
is experiencing symptoms,
and we are now to be
locked down with each other
for 14 days in quarantine.
And we sort of lose our minds,
find each other,
and then somehow decide to
steal a £3 million diamond
from a mass murderer.
-And how did you even get
Harrods to play?
-So, the climax of the movie
takes place in Harrods.
I don't know is the short of it.
I think it's this 2020 thing,
because Doug and Steven
had 40 pages that they said,
"We've got 40 pages, an idea,
but if you don't say yes
to our needing to shoot
the finale of the movie
in your store, there's no point
in us making it.
So can we get
a 'yes' or a 'no'?"
And Harrods said yes.
And you would
expect them to be like,
"We have to call our lawyers.
We have to run it through this.
We have to do market research."
But it was 2020, and they were
like, "You know what?
Why not?"
-It's legendary. It's Harrods.
Come on.
Anyways, I want to show a clip.
Here is Anne Hathaway in
"Locked Down."
Take a look at this.
-£3 million, tax-free,
no consequences.
-One for me, one for you,
one for the NHS.
-You have thought about this.
-You know,
I need to go meditate.
-Well, are you sure they won't
check it in New York?
-Shut up! I need to meditate.
-No, what were you gonna say?
-The man who bought
the diamond is bad.
He's really bad,
and you and I are good.
And the NHS is good,
and good is better than bad.
And when I explained
all that to grandma,
even she said,
"Well, yeah, that's true."
And she was a Calvinist,
straight as a rod,
unlike me, who is weak
in the face of temptation.
-Live wild or die, Linda.
-Anne Hathaway, everybody.
"Locked Down" premieres
this Thursday on HBO Max.